nunca imaginé ser directora de cine no
tenía referentes en realidad yo estaba
bien creía que estaba bien donde estaba
pero un día me tocó ser directora esas
cosas que llaman del destino y entonces
me di cuenta que si podía ser lo que no
había nada que me lo impidiera excepto
que yo misma creyera que si podía
esta pequeña anécdota es el detonante de
el cambio del giro que tuvo mi vida en
el sentido de entender que puedo estar
en otro lugar que en ese sentido muchas
mujeres pueden estar en otro lugar y que
encontré el lugar del feminismo en lo
que hago que es el mundo del cine les
cuento que un día estuve buscando
justamente un dato cuántas mujeres
directoras hay en colombia.y pues no lo
encontré así que me pregunte por qué un
dato tan importante como ese no existe
entonces emprendí la realización de un
estudio una investigación que pudiera
entender esa cifra que pudiera llegar a
ese dato estudiamos desde 1960 hasta el
año 2018 cuerpos de 500 películas
colombianas este año en 1960 es muy
importante porque ahí es donde aparecen
los registros en la investigación la
primera mujer en un rol como productor
la señora felisa 8
y el resultado de esta investigación da
cuenta de que tan sólo el 13 por ciento
es dirigido por mujeres por deducción
entendemos que el 87 por ciento
corresponde a hombres directores qué
significa esta cifra del 13 por ciento
siendo
muchas porque somos tan pocas me
pregunto yo y esto obviamente tiene una
respuesta que es en el pasado
históricamente en las mujeres hemos
tenido un lugar invisibilizado un lugar
silenciado y esto es muy evidente
también en el campo del cine les quiero
hablar de alice y blas y ella realmente
debería ser considerada es considerada
recientemente no hace más de dos décadas
como la primera mujer cineasta incluso
la primera mujer directora la razón es
la siguiente ella creo realmente la
narrativa de ficción fue la pionera de
los efectos especiales fundó su propia
compañía de cine que se llama solares
compañía y compañía por supuesto de su
esposo obviamente en un momento
histórico donde estas cosas eran
bastante extrañas para hacer mujer
dirigió se dice según los historiadores
más de cerca de mil películas de las
cuales infelizmente sólo se pueden
conservar unas 100 entonces uno
porque nadie me habló de alice porque no
está en la historia porque realmente
esta mujer fue borrada ignorada
las respuestas seguramente ustedes ya
las tienen un poco en su mente y en su
cabeza y para mí esto tiene una
respuesta muy importante es porque lo
que no se nombra no existe los sistemas
de silenciamiento que hemos vivido las
mujeres históricamente aún pervive hasta
el día de hoy y esto es una cosa
por la agua en este momento estoy aquí
para contarles esto que es la
importancia digamos de pensar como
mujeres debemos nombrarlos pero lo más
paradigmático del asunto es que somos
las mujeres las más difíciles de
entender ese lugar de que si podemos
tener un lugar de que de alguna manera
podemos no tener miedo hay una metáfora
que yo he empezado a crear y entender un
poco por qué pasa eso ustedes
seguramente han vivido esto están en un
lugar oscuro y salen a la luz del sol o
se prende una luz qué pasa en ese
momento pues uno cierra los ojos porque
porque nos encanta y ya yo creo que eso
mismo hace el feminismo y de alguna
manera es entender que las mujeres hemos
tenido que luchar por la igualdad que
hemos tenido que realmente entender que
no hemos tenido todos los privilegios
que hemos estado en un lugar de sombra
no por eso todo esto a veces nos en
candelilla y quizás esa luz se convierte
en un gran temor para todas para
entender que sí que todos debemos ser
feministas como ha dicho también la
escritura en ingeniería chivas en anda
ha dicho y desde ese lugar de alguna
manera yo me paro así que esta metáfora
de la luz me invita a mí a hacer lo que
hago alquiler y sin él a un laboratorio
cinematográfico virtual para mujeres
está enfocado en formación en
investigación y en visibilizar el cine
de mujeres en colombia resulta que en el
primer laboratorio de formación que
hicimos tuvimos nueve proyectos que
fueron beneficiados de esos nueve
proyectos siete se presentaron a la
convocatoria de financiamiento nacional
en colombia y de esos 73 fueron
ganadores de estímulos financieros para
mí esto fue realmente una gran sorpresa
pero en realidad y obviamente una gran
alegría pero en realidad fue una
confirmación muy grande de lo que
hacemos en killers y similar en cómo es
necesario generar esos espacios de
confianza en que cuando estemos en la
luz no tengamos miedo porque tenemos
esos espacios en los cuales las mujeres
nos podemos escuchar en los cuales las
mujeres podemos sentir esa esa voz
propia que emerge y que realmente
da justamente la voz a esas tantas
expresiones que las mujeres hemos tenido
en la creación del mundo artístico
obviamente frente a esta confirmación
que sufre un killer y sin él pues por
supuesto que es una gran gran motivación
y
pienso pienso realmente en la necesidad
que han de generar esos espacios por eso
de alguna manera mi sueño es crear un
fondo de financiamiento exclusivo para
mujeres para que sea allí realmente
donde podamos acompañar donde se puedan
digamos juntar y donde realmente las
mujeres puedan hablar de sí mismas
puedan nombrarse puedan decir ni tú pero
para decir yo también soy directora yo
también soy cineasta yo también soy
fotógrafa montajista solista
esa es una invitación y algo que me
anima muchísimo en este momento de la
vida y al que también quiero invitar a
todas las mujeres ya todas las personas
de también de cambiar ese lugar del mito
hacia la posibilidad de cómo nos
nombramos y como realmente confiamos en
este proceso de ser mujeres en el mundo